ناشدت الاليه الثلاثيه المسهله للحوار في
السودان وهي الامم المتحده والاتحاد
الافريقي ومنظمه ايجاد جميع الاطراف تهيئه
الظروف اللازمه خلال هذه الفتره لكي يجد
البدنيون الماوى الامن والغذاء والرعايه
الطبيه
واكدت الاليه الثلاثيه على الحاجه الى وقف
فوري ودائم للقتال لتجنب المدنيين
الابرياء في السودان اي اعمال عنف اخرى
وقالت في بيان انها ستواصل العمل من اجل
ذلك بالتنسيق مع اصحاب المصلحه السودانيين
والرباعيه والاتحاد الاوروبي
دنا الاتحاد الاوروبي العمليات العسكريه
بين الجيش السوداني وقوه الدعم السريع ودع
الاتحاد الاوروبي في بيان جميع الاطراف
الى ضمان سلامات المدنيين والعاملين في
المجال الانساني وموظفي البعثات
الدبلوماسيه وحث البيان جميع الاطراف على
وقف القتال فورا ودون شروط كخطوه اولى نحو
اتفاق دائم والسماح بوصول المساعدات
الانسانيه دون عوائق كما رحب البيان بجهود
الوساطه الاقليميه والدوليه باعتبارها
ضروريه لاعاده السودان الى طريق السلام
والاستقرار
وزير الدوله البريطاني للشؤون الافريقيه
في مقابله مع الجزيره قال ان بلاده تعمل
عن كثب ما حلفائها الاقليين والدوليين
لضمان وقف الاشتباكات وحتى الاطراف
المتقاتله على وقف القتال فورا
بريطانيا تنشط مع حلفائها وشركائها ونحن
من يقود ملف السودان في مجلس الامن الامين
العام للامم المتحده دعا جميع الاطراف الى
تسليم سلاحها ونحن نعمل عن قرب مع شركائنا
في المنطقه ومع الاطراف الرئيسيه في الامم
المتحده ودول التراكا يدعو الى انهاء هذه
الاحداث الفظيعه التي تزهق الارواح والتي
تسببت في قتل العاملين في المجال الانساني
بدورها دانه الحكومه الالمانيه بشده
القتال الدائره في السودان وقالت انها
تشعر بفزع من مستوى العنف خصوصا ضد
المدنيين وعمال الاغاثه وطلبت الحكومه
الالمانيه بضروره التزام اطراف النزاع
بوقف فوري لاطلاق النار وتهدئه الموقف في
السودان
تدين الحكومه الالمانيه بشده القتال في
السودان نشعر بالفزع من مستوى العنف خاصه
ضد المدنيين والدبلوماسيين وعمال الاغاثه
ان الاولويات القصوى هي حمايه حياه
الانسان وتهدئه الموقف من المهم ان يتفق
اطراف النزاع على وقف فوري لاطلاق النار
والالتزام به ندعم الجهود الحكوميه
الدوليه للتهدئه وندعم جهود الامم المتحده
على طرفي النزاع الموافقه على عوده
السودان الى الحكم المدني الشعب السوداني
يحارب من سنوات من اجل نظام ديمقراطي
من جانبه قال وزير الخارجيه التركي
ان بلاده تجري محادثات مع الاطراف
المتصارعه في السودان من اجل الوصول الى
هدنه ووقف الاشتباكات واكد تشاو شغله
موافقه الاطراف على هدنه في السودان اليوم
الخميس
نتواصل مع الطرفين من اجل وقف الاشتباكات
نتواصل مع نائب الرئيس من جهه ومع قائد
قوات الدعم السريع من جهه اخرى تركيا تجري
محادثات مع الاطراف المتحاربه في السودان
لوقف الحرب ستكون هناك هدنه يوم الخميس ان
شاء الله ومن هذا المقام نطمان مواطنين
هناك والراغبين في العوده انه سيتم
اجلائهم عند اعاده فتح المجال الجوي وهناك
العديد من الدول بما في ذلك دول اوروبيه
طلبت المساعده من تركيا لاجلاء رعاياها من
السودان